hi there today a friend will be
challenging me to take a popular food
and make it fancy today's guest eats
andrew rie i want to challenge you to
make eggnog fancy in the winter a warm
cup of eggnog is one of the best things
to have i've always wondered what are
other ways that i could enjoy this treat
so i want to see you make eggnog fancy
and see what you come up with eggnog
i've never had eggnog before very
controversial drink it seems like this
one is non-alcoholic but typically
served with alcohol
yellow
[Music]
oh it's very sweet milkshake almost but
with egg i prefer milkshake
it's so creamy the spice definitely have
a like holiday christmas feeling to it i
think flavor-wise it's good it's just uh
i don't want to drink this i have some
great idea and i'm excited to make it
fancy
all right here's what i got heavy cream
butter cream cheese eggs from the pantry
i got flour brown sugar meringue powder
gelatin powder condensed milk salt
vanilla extract nutmeg allspice cinnamon
powdered sugar lemon baking powder
sprinkles food coloring and spice rum
all right let's get started
make it fancy
so first add room temperature butter i
have two sticks and a half one cup of
brown sugar mix them together using
standard mixture i'm going to mix until
light and fluffy and the color is a
little bit lighter add egg yolk one by
one
make sure each yolks are well
incorporated and scrape the side okay so
all the eggs are incorporated so i'm
going to add a quarter cup of egg milk
if you don't have stone mixer you can
use hana mixer or you can use whisk but
it will take longer we are using spiced
rum i think it's gonna be a nice
additional adult holiday flavor and i'm
adding one
tablespoon george washington had his own
recipe oh
and it had rye
whiskey
rum and cherry it's the original triple
alcohol yeah back then they didn't have
internet but they had alcohol i'm going
to make my flour mixture pinch of
allspice half teaspoon of cinnamon
quarter teaspoon of salt 1 teaspoon of
baking powder grate nutmeg about half a
teaspoon
ah
grate it to my finger and lightly mix
i'm gonna add half
rest of them you want to mix until you
won't see any visible flower bits
transfer this dough
into a plastic wrap it tight and rest
this dough in a refrigerator about two
hours two hours later you need plastic
from this dough i'm going to measure 10
seeds between two parchment paper i'm
adding dough and start rolling still
cold so it's a little bit
tough to roll but gradually softening up
so you want to roll out about 1 8 inch
thickness and about 11 inch diameter and
i'm going to line this door use your
finger
line
into the tarp mode use rolling pin and
roll over a couple times and it will
naturally fall looks like a magic we are
going to duck this dough so when you
duck this it doesn't puffs up and it
doesn't shrink i'm going to put this in
the freezer for 20 minutes bake up 450
for 5 minutes then lower the temperature
to 350 and bake another 15 minutes i
have rest of the dough right here and
i'm going to roll same way this dough is
still a little bit tough so you can kind
of top it and make it easier to roll
just take off the top parchment paper
i'm using star-shaped cookie cutter and
a dust with flour
making star shaped cookie
and you're gonna line in a parchment
paper you kind of want to push from
behind and unmold it i'm going to unmold
this and bake a 350 for 10 minutes
quarter cup of egg not quarter cup of
heavy cream quarter cup of brown sugar 1
tablespoon of butter mix it until well
combined bring it to a boil and cook
about five minutes whisk occasionally
back in the 1800s eggnog was used to
treat diseases was it alcohol in there i
cook about five minutes and it's kind of
bubbly and it looks thicker and i'm
gonna start whisking constantly from
this point because you don't want
mixture to be burnt and i'm going to
cook about two more minutes it smells
good this looks done very thick pour
this into a
heat safe glass bowl set this aside to
cool in room temperature and moving on
to the next step one tablespoon of water
and sprinkle one and half teaspoon of
gelatin let it bring about five minutes
while i'm waiting mix cream cheese with
hand mixer until fluffy
seven ounces of condensed milk and once
it's well mixed add in half cup of egg
milk
one tablespoon of lemon juice
and add in a half teaspoon of vanilla
extract quarter teaspoon of cinnamon
powder about 1 8 teaspoon of nutmeg
blend well
[Applause]
tablespoon of hot water to bloomed
gelatin make sure it's all melted in hot
water gelatin into the mixture and
mix well
strain this mixture so i can make sure
this is smooth okay mixture is ready but
i have more things to do my tart shell
is baked and cool and i transfer my
mixture into pizza so i can easily pour
and this is the eggnog butterscotch i
made pour this mixture and you don't
want to overfill it give a nice drop of
butterscotch
using skewers and it kind of makes nice
pattern just a free form pattern looks
pretty and i'm going to chill this in
the refrigerator about 6 hours 4 cup of
powdered sugar quarter cup of meringue
powder and mix well add water start with
4 tbsp first and adding more water until
desired consistency so i added meringue
powder it's faster to set if you add it
but if you don't have meringue powder
you can just add egg whites or corn
syrup and water but it will take longer
to set this is a good consistency it's
runny like this because i'm going to
pipe it divide into three balls and i'm
adding one with green photo coloring and
this one is red i'm gonna add this
into a piping bag and green
white
my eggnog cookies are baked and cold now
i'm going to decorate with icing and
sprinkles it's just a
freestyle you want to kind of draw the
outline and kind of fill the space and
while it's still wet i'm going to just
put some
red white sprinkles i think also it's
kind of cute if you put like big
sprinkles to kind of look like rudolph
put the green sprinkle so this one i'm
going to
decorate it look like a snowflake this
is probably my favorite pattern
okay my holiday cookies looks very
festive but we are not done yet a cup of
heavy cream 2 tbsp of eggnog quarter cup
of powdered sugar half teaspoon of
nutmeg i'm gonna use imagine blender mix
it until stiff peak add spiced rum one
tablespoon i usually use
whisk but i think this is a cool trick
transfer this into a piping bag
and we're gonna use it later this is a
tart i was resting in a refrigerator and
it's set now and i'm going to decorate
using star tip and piping straight if
you want to make bigger star just press
and hold it and make it bigger and if
you want to make it smaller stars you
can just like lightly squeeze i'm
placing bigger cookies first and small
cookies around it
so it kind of looks like a milky way and
filling with
eggnog cream
the gap and we are done
[Music]
holiday eggnog tar
very festive
i have a christmas gift for you really
yeah
oh a hat i was like it's this cake right
thank you fancy cup
i think that's big
i made eggnog fancy as you challenged me
this does look so fancy is that what
this is butterscotch this little flower
design that's the kind of thing where i
look at it and i'm like i will never
make desserts as well as whoever made
this is this face is this like a person
it was inspired by
uh
rudolph so is there booze in this tart
yes always
i mean look at that you always have a
very particular way of inspecting i like
to get it onto my uh my same elevation
mm-hmm then
i also like to really smell something
cheers cheers
this is a treat thank you this is like
what i dream of when i think of
a holiday
treat all right andre do you remember
what we do after
yeah you do like some
john travolta discovery
he had his own version actually
did i
yeah
three two one make it fancy
[Music]
you